[Music]
Robert thank you so much for being here
with me I appreciate it so talk to me
about your founding story I want to hear
the whole history of bearbottom okay
yeah it's a long story so we started
about 10 years ago when I was in high
school I had the idea um I had the
opportunity to go overseas with my
father who's been in the apparel
industry you know my whole life and I
saw like production and huge factories
producing for like some of the world's
largest Brands and just got that
exposure then I came home uh to Florida
in the middle of win I needed some
shorts cuz it doesn't get cold there and
I couldn't find shorts that like suited
what I was looking for and at a good
price point um and that's when I talked
to my dad I said you know what does it
cost to produce these you know what's
that look like got some more information
and I said how hard could it be to sell
shorts online right um so that was my
idea and then he said yeah go ahead and
try it not thinking I was serious and
about a year later um I went I interned
in Hong Kong and like learned about
production and sourcing product
development I was at the University of
Florida at the time uh after that
internship and then built the website
got our first shipment of 10,000 pieces
and started selling shorts online from
then and then uh when we founded the
company we had the mission of donating a
pair of shorts for everyone we sold um
just thinking back like to my trip to
Bangladesh in particular um and just
seeing you know that country and how
much the people you know could use some
support and that was like our founding
Mission and since then we've shifted a
little bit but that's kind of the five
minute you know quick version of our
story that is a great Mission thank you
for sharing that so talk to me about the
types of clothes you you produce and who
exactly is your target market definitely
um so we produce only Men's Wear right
now uh it's super comfortable like daily
clothing that you wear you know we
always like to produce stuff for our
team so any time we're going somewhere
or not wearing our product we designed
something for that so we have active we
have like casual Basics um like shirts
like this things that are a little more
dressy you could wear out to dinner that
sort of thing um a lot of our customers
are they're throughout the country you
know we just sell through our website so
Florida New York California Texas really
everywhere um and people who like to get
Outdoors who are you know passionate
about what they do so we like to say
everyday Adventure is what we design for
so whether you're into music hiking um
business really whatever it is like our
product is made for you very cool now is
it in any stores or is it only online we
just sell through our website okay how
has that process been like for you and
do is the goal to eventually get into uh
that's been pretty intentional um it's
good it keeps us like super focused on
what we're doing and instead of like
spreading ourselves too thin and like
going through all these different
channels obviously we know there's a lot
of opportunity in like wholesale and
like retail now more so than ever I
think for e-commerce Brands um it's
becoming a bigger opportunity I guess
where you can really get your brand out
there but we like we're designed for
e-commerce like that that's our process
right now and uh we think we can
continue growing that way for a while
you don't hear Too Many people say that
they started their company in high
school what make you think that what
made you think that you could actually
take that dive into entrepreneurship so
young uh I think part of it was I was
young you know I was naive I just kind
of thought how like I said how hard
could it be to sell shorts online I was
very naive uh but that's kind of just
you know I started it really when I was
in college and I think that was a real
opportunity for me cuz I didn't have too
much pressure you know I didn't I wasn't
an adult I wasn't looking for jobs I
wasn't like doing this as a side gig you
know I was going to class obviously and
like having my friendship and social
life but outside of that I was like all
right let me figure out how to sell
shorts online so it's pretty much just
that basic there's so many you know
men's are Brands out there there today
both in you know just the e-commerce and
the startup scene like you but also
incumbents that have been around for
years how are you working to to stand
out and make people choose bare bottom
over any others definitely yeah we try
to provide a lot of value to our
customers in both like product quality
like we are designing for ourselves so
that helps a lot like we have a ton of
passion into product that's like my
passion is like production and product
so we have a huge focus on that and then
customer experience um every single
product review we read our whole team
reads our customer service team responds
to any review that's not a festar review
I get emailed to me our Co gets emailed
to me we share those reviews and
feedback with our Factory so we really
do care a lot and like that's again what
it comes down to everyone on our team is
super passionate about our product and
making sure our customers you know get
the same experience that we want to have
as a customer with any other type of
brand interesting now you're totally
bootstrapped which I think is really
incredible have you thought about taking
on any outside Investments or do you
want to in the future uh We've looked
into it briefly but you know we like how
we can operate the team without having
like outside influences we have some
good mentors um that we're able to
bounce ideas off of and network within
other brands who are in the same space
which is really cool um we like to have
you know people who are really
competitors of ours they're willing to
share and we're willing to share with
them so I like that relationship but
right now we don't really plan on
raising any funds or anything like that
and talk to me about your sales growth
over the past few years yeah so Co um
was really where we saw huge Spike we've
grown consistently since I started the
business but after Co um we really like
skyrocketed the first couple weeks were
really rough um and then just was like a
really steady increase from there um and
we've been growing ever since that's
really cool can you share any of your
Revenue metrics or any other yeah so
this year we're expecting about $25
million in Revenue wow so that's amazing
congrats thank you what has been the
most challenging part of running your
company um there's a lot of challenges I
think between you know production issues
and finding new customers and how to be
with customers and you know solving
those types of things I think it's just
there's a different challenge every day
honestly so I don't know if there's been
like one that stands out necessarily
that's fair is there any world in which
you would consider selling your company
and what would it take for you to do
that uh I have no vision of doing that
right now I you know I love the team
we've built and part of our company and
like how we like to operate obviously
one we want to grow our business but
with that we want to grow the people on
our team so you know personal growth
growing their skills obviously you know
we want them to continue and improve in
the partners we work with so the
factories we work with we don't go in
place one order these are true Partners
they come to our family events like they
come visit us all the time I go there um
so it's a true relationship so I we all
want to grow together and that's our
mission we're not really looking for you
know 5 years we're seeing how do we
could build this to be like a monster
business in 50 50 years from now very
cool I want to touch on um your
marketing and your strategy for
acquiring new customers is social media
a large driver of that and talk to me
about which route you decided to go and
why so social media is huge um that's
our Core Business Like growth vessel uh
vehicle so we grow through social media
paid social organic social those are
really big channels for us is there any
advice that you wish you knew on day one
of founding your company that you'd give
yourself now yes definitely um on day
one it would probably have been forecast
your ordering better uh my first order I
did not not do a good job and I had as
many yellow and pink shorts as I did
Navy and black which was a strategic
mistake um but that was a small mistake
I would say like the biggest lesson I
wish I knew then is how important it is
to have a strong team around you um like
once we started adding like really good
members to our team as one in our
business really started to grow a lot
and see the success we see now what's
your best selling item speaking of all
those different types of shorts uh
actually the first product we started
selling which was our stretch shorts now
is it's a later version and it's had a
lot of improvements basically every
single thing about it is new but that's
still our bestselling item as someone
who does not often buy men's clothes
what what's different about it or
exciting um so they're super comfortable
they have an elastic waistband which is
not very common in men's clothing but
they're cotton spandex fabric so they
have some stretch to them they're super
uh soft Garin eyed we offer different
inseams they're pretty short uh compared
to most shorts so I think that's like a
big differentiator for them is there one
uh piece of business advice or a
business rule that you always follow no
matter what it's a good question I think
the main thing is just like being
authentic and treating people how you
want to be treated like that's how we
work with our partners like I said and I
think that's pretty important very cool
now I want to talk about the future okay
what is coming up for you what exciting
things are in the pipeline and in uh 24
that you could maybe share with us
perfect yeah uh we have a ton of product
development going on this year we
launched a lot of new products outside
of our typical category so we had some
different matching sets a lot more
performance fabrics and things like that
we have a treatment called hexar which
is like a graphine fabric treatment and
it gives over seven properties like UPF
protection
antimicrobial uh quick drying all
different features so we have a lot of
technical Fabrics coming up which I'm
really excited about and like I said
like new Styles a little bit outside of
what we typically have been offering do
you ever want to get into women's
clothing in the future or yeah we get
that question a lot um especially from
like the members of our team that are
female they do wear a lot of our
products though a lot of it is unisex so
we get a lot of reviews from women
buying our product talking about how
they love the fit how they love the
pockets um so there is you know we do
have some Crossover with that but right
now we don't have plans for women's but
not saying it's not possible in the
future yeah um and one final question
for you Robert what would you like your
legacy to be that's cool I think uh main
thing for my legacy would probably be
like that we helped a lot of people
along the way whether we helped them
grow our production partners and uh you
know for every item we sell right now we
donate a meal to a child in need so
we're going to soon surpass 1 million
meals donated so I think as long as you
know people can remember us for doing
something like that I think that'll be
really awesome awesome well thank you so
much for being here I appreciate it
thanks for the
[Music]
time